Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linold. Guten Morgen Tim.
Ausspielen und da Freunden. Geht das eigentlich?
Geht gar nicht.
Lockbuchen Netzpolitik, einhundertsiebzehn, schönen guten Tag, hier spricht der Tim. Dahinten spricht der Linos. Hallo Dinos.
Moin.
Wir wieder endlich mal hier an einem Ort versammelt. Ist auch gut. Jetzt trommeln die schon auf den Tisch. Das soll man nicht beim Podcasten.
Mhm. Ja, das soll man nicht. Nicht essen, nicht auf den Tisch trommeln.
Disziplin. Disziplin ist angesagt.
Ja.
Ja genau, heute wollen wir auch mal schauen, wie diszipliniert sich denn so unsere Umwelt äh verhält,
Ähm wieder so ein paar Updates gekommen zur Vervollständigung der Geschichtsbetrachtung der letzten zehn Jahre. Ich habe so den Eindruck, das kommt so langsam wie so ein kleines Musa Mosaikbild äh,
zusammen. Ansonsten gab's ähm ja, positive Rückmeldungen auf unseren Veranstaltungs äh Blog. Sehr schön.
Ja. Und teilweise auch mal, also das das vielleicht ein äh das ist etwas, was ich in den letzten Wochen irgendwie,
Monaten vielleicht beobachte, dass ich erstmals irgendwie so ein paar Leute in den Kommentaren verirren, die irgendwie nicht so eine ähm,
Nicht so eine äh konservative Sozialisation, wie ich hinter sich haben, was so Höflichkeit angeht in in den Äußerungen und im Umgang mit anderen Menschen. Ähm.
Da würde ich äh echt einfach bitten, so einen normalen Umgangston beizubehalten, ja, wenn man da irgendwie halbwegs normal mit mir spricht, dann kriegt man auch eine halbwegs normale Antwort und äh ansonsten kann man das vielleicht äh auch so einlassen.
Finde ich auch, finde ich auch wichtig.
Also so viel mehr jetzt irgendwie vor vor ein paar Wochen zum ersten Mal auf das Teil halt äh.
Ohnehin so ein aufkommendes äh äh Meterthema so und äh ich denke so auch so die Kommunikationshygiene dann aber auch ähm aktiv zu betreuen äh ist sinnvoll, ja.
Also wir sind natürlich nach wie vor mit also als mit dem Podcast bist du, hast du jetzt alles andere als oder vor allem mit diesem Portraits hast du jetzt alles andere als irgendein großartige Treuproblematik oder so, ne? Also da äh ist man anderes gewohnt. Aber umso ähm,
umso auffälliger ist es dann halt, wenn wenn das manchmal wenn davon abgewichen wird,
Was du gerade ansprichst ist natürlich, es wird jetzt grade auch mal wieder in verschiedenen Communitys eben auch so dieser der Umgangston ähm und der Respekt miteinander äh voreinander äh diskutiert,
Open-Source-Community ist da gerade äh,
sage mal ein paar Sachen äh zu hinterfragen, wie was die was den Umgangston angeht, ne, Piratenpartei, ähm,
streitet sich da auch drüber und ähm ja,
Also ich ich rate da halt einfach dazu, ähm vielleicht unter Umständen in mal kurz zu berücksichtigen, dass es sich hierbei um ein
freiwilliges und kostenloses Angebot handelt, dass ihr nicht gezwungen seid zu hören, wenn es euch nicht gefällt.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man elektronisch kommuniziert, äh sagt nichts, was ihr nicht auch sagen würdet, wenn äh die betreffende angesprochene Person direkt vor stehen würde. Das äh finde ich, ist schon mal ganz ganz sinnvoll.
Ja, man muss also was ich auch wirklich, äh was was bei dieser schriftlichen Kommunikation immer so ein Problem ist, ähm.
Das beste Beispiel ist ähm Fefe. Wenn der schreibt,
Ja, das das liest sich irgendwie so absolut bitter böse und gemein und und äh fürchterlich, ja. Aber wenn man ähm dann wenn er halt spricht
Ja, dann, dann wirkt das schon wieder ganz anders, ja, weil man halt weiß, dass er einfach nur ein völlig albern ist. Ja, dass das heißt, äh selbst die die übelsten Beleidigungen
äh wirken halt anders, wenn er, wenn er spricht, als wenn man jetzt so seinen Blog liest, wo er ja äh teilweise wirklich Gift und Galle über über äh
Sachverhalte oder Personen ergießt, ja? Und ähm das, das denke ich, das ist immer so ein gutes Beispiel für ähm.
Äh für für geschriebene Sprache, wie unterschiedlich die halt dann auch wirkt.
Ja, vor allem,
die Interpretation des Rezipienten einfach so offen zu halten, ne? Also man interpretiert das dann halt so,
wie es einem grad passt. So, wenn man irgendwie schlecht gelaunt ist, dann dann ist halt auch irgendwie alles übel gelaunt, was auf einen zukommt
Da muss man schon ein bisschen an sich selber drehen, was so die Kommunikationskanäle betrifft, man ja so in diesen öffentlichen ähm Welten wie Twitter, et cetera, da ist es halt,
problematisch, ne? Mailinglisten, die ja im Prinzip auch schon so ein bisschen äh immer so als als Schlachtplatz äh des Netzes ähm galten und das auch,
Sehr zurecht, ja. Gibt's auch immer wieder gute und schlechte Beispiele, aber es hat eben auch viel mit Moderation zu tun und ähm,
Ich habe mal eine Mailingliste gestartet, wo ich irgendwie von Anfang an immer gesagt habe, okay, wir lassen jetzt hier jeden auch erstmal drauf so, aber wir hier irgendwie äh vom vom freundlichen Ton,
abweicht, so kann sich 'ne andere Medienliste suchen. Ist einfach hier nicht der Ort, so und das, das, das funktioniert dann auch.
Kann man dann eben auch äh durchziehen. Na ja, so viel mal dazu.
Dass er, wie gesagt, ich sehe das jetzt auch nicht als als ein als ein großes Problem an, aber ähm wird das so grundsätzlich mal anmerken, ja, also wollte ich mal loswerden. Ich habe da auch, glaube ich.
Unser kleiner Netz politischer äh Knigge hier an der Stelle.
Und dann empfehle ich natürlich zu dem Thema.
Wer sich politisch durchsetzen will, muss freundlich sein, um es mal ein bisschen zu adaptieren, ja.
Ich empfehle dann noch die äh die alternativlos Folge Nummer äh weiß ich gar nicht genau, ich glaube einunddreißig.
Die Trollfolge.
Über Diskursform im Internet featuring Trolle, Mimis und empörere Frank Fefe und meine Wenigkeit haben sich da ein bisschen mit auseinandergesetzt.
Gut, kommen wir mal raus hier aus der Eigenwerbung.
Genau.
Und rein ins äh wilde Geschehen. Äh wusstest du, was ist?
Ähm nein, also aber äh ich wusste nicht, dass es so heißt, denn diese, das ist ja, also äh alconal.
Also was es eigentlich ist.
Das stand in dem süddeutschen Artikel drin, ein ein äh irgendein optisches Phänomen.
Ein Phänomen. Das ist schlicht die Strecke zwischen dem einen und dem Aus äh Tritzpunkt, also sozusagen der, die eigentliche äh Strecke, an der das Licht durch äh die Glasfaser wandert.
Das ist das lädt so ein bisschen ein äh wieder schlechtes,
sächsisches zu sprechen, worüber sich Sachsen vollkommen zurecht äh aufregen dürften, lädt aber trotzdem dazu ein.
Ähm ja auf jeden Fall
Alconal ist so ein bisschen das äh äh NSA der äh Woche. Wobei ist das überhaupt ein NSA-Term oder ist das an der Stelle ein BND-Term?
Na ja, auf jeden Fall, wir haben ja schon häufiger äh angesprochen. Es gibt immer diese merkwürdigen Meldungen über die ganzen
letzten zwei, also übers letzte Jahr vor allem natürlich, aber immer so Vermutungen, na ja, dass halt auch Netzknoten, wie vor allem, natürlich der, äh, die Ezix, ähm, ja, ab
abgehorcht werden oder auch geschnorchelt,
so ein bisschen unklar, das hat man schon gerechnet, dass ab und zu mal ein Ohr aufgemacht wird. Ja, natürlich nur, wenn's einen äh Richterbeschluss gibt, et cetera. Äh aber im letzten Jahr hat sich das Ganze ja eher so dargestellt, dass da irgendjemand auch irgendwie schnorchelt,
und äh ja, es fragt sich halt immer, wer wer denn nun eigentlich und äh die NSA stand so ein bisschen im Verdacht, aber man fragte sich dann immer, ja wo denn, wo ist denn da das Kabel.
Nee, das war, also es, das Thema als solches, im Sommer zweitausenddreizehn, was zum ersten Mal im Spiegel, dass der Spiegel gesagt hat, ja, äh der BND überwacht den Dezix.
Und,
Hat dann damals gesagt, ja äh können da nichts zu sagen, wie hier was stattfindet, aber äh ist uns irgendwie nicht bekannt und ähm gehen sie bitte weiter, ja?
Die Ein- und Ausleitung.
Genau, dann haben hat der CCC
im Februar zweitausend äh vierzehn, dann die äh Strafanzeige auch erstattet gegen äh die Bundesregierung. Und da äh war ich mal bei der Tagesschau kurz und habe dann äh denen auch gesagt, ähm,
Das quasi eine Internetüberwachung,
in Deutschland, in dem Ausmaß äh durch die NSA nicht passieren kann, ohne Mitwissen oder Unterstützung deutscher Dienste. Das heißt, entweder lassen die es zu oder sie helfen dabei. Und das war eigentlich technisch schon immer,
Klar, dass das nicht, du kriegst nicht diese Datenmenge aus dem Dezex raus, ähm ohne dass dass da irgendwie, sage ich mal, zumindest die, die Dienste was von mitbekommen.
Immerhin einer der größten Netzknoten, wenn nicht, glaube ich, sogar mittlerweile sogar der größte äh Netzknoten des Internets. Also äh nicht ganz uninteressant.
Und dann äh wurde im Juli nochmal dann von durch Frontal einundzwanzig äh berichtet. Ja, der der BND hat da eine feste Standleitung zum zum Dezix, um da äh auch zwischen Schnorcheln,
Und jetzt wurde äh auf Basis von Akten des Kanzleramts und des BNDs, recherchiert von NDR, WDR und Süddeutsche.
Der Süddeutschen Zeitung eben erklärt, okay es gab eine Zusammenarbeit zwischen dem BND und der NSA zwischen zweitausendvier und zweitausendacht
zu dem Zeitpunkt, ne, war jetzt diese ganze nine eleven Geschichte noch relativ äh frisch und äh der zu dem Zeit,
zu dem Zeitpunkt Kanzleramtsminister Steinmeier war guter Freund mit dem äh BND-Chef Hanning
und die haben sich natürlich um ihre uneingeschränkte Solidarität gekümmert.
Die ja vom Bundeskanzler Schröder ausgerufen wurde.
Genau und ähm haben dann in Frankfurt ab zweitausendvier Telefonverkehr überwacht und ähm November zweitausendfünf auch äh,
Internetverkehr und das Ganze mit Technik, die sie aus den USA bekommen haben. Ähm,
die der ganze Aufbau war dann so wie ich das glaube ich auf irgendeiner Folge mal hier ungefähr erklärt habe. Du hast ähm,
einen groben Filter direkt an Ort und Stelle, also in Frankfurt, der dann zum Beispiel äh die ganzen YouTube-Video,
Inhalte, ja, also das eigentliche Video, zum Beispiel rausfiltert, weil den ganzen Mistwitz, den ich noch mal, das ist viel Bandbreite, die du brauchst und.
Das ist ja eh Public, das kann man sich bei Bedarf dann eh selber ziehen.
Ist E-Public.
Beziehungsweise woanders.
Genau, das kannst du halt zu Hause gucken, wenn du wenn es notwendig ist, aber du brauchst es nicht mit abzuhören. Das heißt, sie schneiden ähm die Teile ähm an Ort und Stelle raus, die jetzt nicht,
Spiegel notwendig sind, ja? Dadurch reduzierst du halt schon mal so ein bisschen, aber du schmeißt natürlich auch nur die Sachen weg, von denen du ganz sicher weißt, dass du sie
jetzt in diesem Moment nicht brauchst, weil sie sich andauernd wiederholen, ne, so ein YouTube-Video wird,
unglaublich oft auch geschaut. Ähm insofern filterst du das natürlich dann äh aus deinem Datenstrom raus. Und ähnliche Vorfiltern, ja, also quasi Dinge, die dich nicht wirklich interessieren, schneidest du halt raus.
Aber die Dinge, die dich nicht interessieren, sind eigentlich hauptsächlich nur Bandbreiten, starke,
Dinge, die ohnehin öffentlich sind. Und Dinge, die sich sehr häufig wiederholen, wo du dann halt ein bisschen voroptimierst und sagen wir mal, statt der, der gesamten Seite vielleicht da,
deiner Station nur noch äh übergibst, der hat schon wieder diese Seite aufgerufen, aber die hat sich nicht geändert seitdem und deswegen schicke ich die jetzt nicht nochmal mit, da kannste,
gucken, ne, also bisschen äh vorgefiltert. Ähm dann geht eine Leitung nach Pullach.
Und da steht dann irgendwie, da war mir jetzt nicht ganz klar, ob in einigen Berichten hieß es für diese Leitung wäre die Telekom bezahlt worden an anderen Stellen
äh stand für diese Vorfilteranlage. Die Hardware, die dafür notwendig wäre, äh sei die Telekom bezahlt worden, vielleicht auch beides. Aber es flossen äh ungefähr sechstausend Euro im Monat an die Telekom.
Was nicht viel ist. Klingt mir so nach Leitung.
Ja, also äh wie gesagt, das da war ich mir jetzt nicht sicher, in dem, da, ich fühle mich da eher auf die Primärkälle ähm süddeutsche beziehen und da hieß es halt irgendwie Hardware.
Ähm und von Pullach, also wo der BND sitzt, von da ging's dann nach Bad Aibling,
wo dann eben BND und NSA äh sitzen. Das war der Teil, den wir letzte Woche auch schon besprochen hatten, wo der äh gute PR oder wie der hieß JZ, wie die alle hießen, im NSA U A keine ähm,
Aussagegenehmigungen hatten. So und jetzt haben sie äh,
Interessanterweise war die äh hatte die äh hatten die USA quasi den den Standort,
Bad Aibling offiziell zweitausendvier da auch aufgegeben und sind dann da auch irgendwie mit ihren Fahnen rausgeritten oder so und haben aber dann halt nebenan diesen schönen ähm
Metall verpackten äh Raum gebaut, in denen sie dann eingezogen sind. All das hatten wir äh letzte Woche schon besprochen. So und jetzt kommt der der äh,
Teil, der dann wieder natürlich den wie legal war dieser ganze Kram. Ja und jetzt wird gesagt ähm,
Es wäre also ein ein Filtersystem mit dem Namen Davis. Ich glaube, das steht wahrscheinlich für Datenfiltersystem oder sowas.
Huhu, ist aber sehr gewagt jetzt die.
Äh sollte dann die Daten deutscher Bürger heraus filtern. Ähm,
da wird jetzt in dem süddeutsch Artikel nicht konkreter gesagt wie der funktioniert hat, aber wir erinnern uns an eben solche ähm,
Veröffentlichung, die dann auch hauptsächlich von Netzpolitik org äh vorangetrieben wurden, wo es um die äh Top-Level.
Von E-Mails ging.
Top-Level Domain von E-Mails und ähnliche Scherze, ja, also ähm auch da haben wir ja schon ausführlich darüber gesprochen, dass es sehr, sehr schwierig ist.
Denn nur du weißt ja, nur nur wo DE dransteht, ist auch Deutschland drin.
Genau. Äh ist natürlich relativ schwierig festzustellen, äh ob jetzt der Kommunikationspartner am anderen Ende,
Deutsch ist oder nicht und ja also man könnte das jetzt vielleicht an an IP-Adressen festmachen,
ähm aber es ist also klar, man kann keinen man kann auf,
Internetdatenstrom dieser Menge nicht einfach einen Filter setzen, der sagt, deutsche Kommunikationspartner ausklammern. Das ist eben ein Internet und ähm entsprechend ist es auch inter,
Ähm,
Jetzt haben sie aber diesen Datenfilter gebaut und behaupten jetzt einfach, dass es so eine Zahl, die äh die Journalisten da jetzt einfach auch übernehmen. Der hätte ja fünfundneunzig Prozent äh Genauigkeit gehabt. Was ich interessant finde, weil.
Auch das kann nur eine Schätzung sein, weil du kannst diese du kannst es ja nicht verifizieren. Ja, also wenn du sagst, der hat,
Wenn du wenn du die Genauigkeit bestimmen kannst, dann sagst du, er ist fünfundneunzig Prozent genau, dann siehst du ja auch, wo er nicht genau ist und könntest ihn nachadjustieren. Ja? Das heißt, es ist eine, das ist eine reine Fantasiezahl.
Also man muss sich auch die Fünf-Prozent im Prinzip genau angeschaut haben. Und überprüft haben.
Ja man, man. Genau und das haben sie ja nicht. Also äh diese fünfundneunzig Prozent, das ist halt dieses klassische Ding, ne, wir sagen eine Zahl mit einer neuen vorne, äh die klingt groß. Ja, und sagen Prozent, ja.
So wie früher, so äh Internet Provider irgendwie damit äh angegeben haben, das Jahr neunundneunzig prozentige Zuverlässigkeit äh haben. Und wenn man das mal ausrechnet, das heißt so drei Tage im Jahr fällt alles aus.
Fällt das aus, ja. Für fünfundneunzig Prozent.
So, hm, dann haben sie dann irgendwann nochmal einen Neuen nochmal dran gehangen.
Genau und das ist aber natürlich irgendwie ein absoluter äh also schon.
Reinmethodisch kannst du diese Genauigkeit nicht bestimmen, in diesem Fall, weil sie ja selber, da kommt natürlich auch dieser Teil rein, wo sie sagen, wir haben die meisten Daten sammeln wir zwar, aber den nur den kleinsten Teil davon, schauen wir uns an, weil unsere Gehirne zu klein sind
Und wenn wir das automatisch verarbeiten, dann ist es, dann ist es ja automatisch verarbeitet und deswegen nicht äh nicht überwacht. Ähm.
Also diese Zahl fünfundneunzig Prozent ist halt natürlich so absolute Augenwischerei, aber trotzdem.
Ja, vor allem, wenn man das wirklich jetzt mal auf die deutschen Bürger hochrechnet, äh, heißt es, dass sozusagen vier Millionen deutsche Bürger da äh mal lockere durchrutschen.
Und nicht nur zum BND, der,
Inland Überwachung sowieso nicht betreiben darf, sondern der reicht's dann automatisch an die NSA weiter. Und da hat dann auch BND intern gab es dann da Bedenken,
Da gesagt wurde, hey, wir wir können das hier gar nicht voll vollständig kontrollieren. Ähm,
und wenn die hat also ein ein Mitarbeiter des PND äh sich gesagt, so selbst wenn die USA uns zusichern, sich an unsere Gesetze zu halten, können wir das wegen unserer technischen Unterlegenheit,
überhaupt nicht überprüfen. Ja, das heißt, wir wir verlassen uns hier auf deren Wort, verstoßen selber gegen das Gesetz und,
helfen denen dabei, äh etwas zu tun, was äh eigentlich eben auch nicht in äh in Ordnung ist. Und ähm,
Da sagte der BND Mitarbeiter war da von einer äh gewissen Weitsicht geprägt und sagte, die gesamte verschlüsselte Kommunikation, die können wir ja inhaltlich überhaupt nicht beurteilen. Das heißt, da können ja auch nochmal Deutsche drin sein und wir wissen ja nicht.
Ob die Amis nicht ohnehin entweder diesen äh diese Krypto knacken können oder sowieso den Secret Key haben und das alles äh irgendwie dann bei sich nochmal entschlüsseln. Das heißt, ähm,
Wir haben hier wirklich ein äh Problem und dann wurde halt vom vom BND auch das Bundeskanzleramt gefragt, äh ob sie denn das G zehn Gremium über diese Operation informieren müssen,
Und die Antwort äh scheint dann irgendwie wohl gewesen zu sein, müsst ihr wohl nicht. Ähm und.
Gesetzliche Hintergrund ist eben der die Weitergabe von Telefondaten und Mailverkehr von Deutschen an ausländische Dienste ist nur unter strengsten Voraussetzungen und nur im Einzelfall zulässig und hier kann man natürlich nicht von einem Einzelfall reden.
Ähm Fakt ist, der Steinmeier als Kanzleramtsminister muss zugestimmt haben,
Denn es gab es gab Kommunikation und zwar genaue enge Absprachen zwischen Bundeskanzleramt und BND in diesem Fall. Ähm,
Thomas de Maizire, der dann äh sein Nachfolger war, hat die Operation erstmal weiterlaufen lassen.
Und währenddessen äh sitzen wir äh vorm Fernseher und schauen uns solche Äußerungen an wie ähm,
abhören unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht,
Da gab's jetzt auch eine sehr schöne Frage in der äh Bundespressekonferenz, äh wo dann gesagt wurde, sagen sie mal Herr Seibert, heißt das, äh dass sich die Bundeskanzlerin, als sie abhören unter Freunden geht gar nicht gesagt hat
nicht nur auf das bezogen hat, was über die Unterlagen von Herrn Snowden berichtet wurde, sondern dass sie zu diesem Zeitpunkt ganz genau wusste, was passiert war und sich konkret zu Informationen geäußert hat,
die sie selbst hatte.
Also mit anderen Worten, wenn die Kanzlerin sich hinstellt, äh und sagt, abhören unter Freunden geht gar nicht, meint sie damit dann doch nur sich selbst oder meint sie alle deutschen Bürger? Und in dem Fall hätte sie ja dann,
gelogen. Und dann sagt der Seibert, ich glaube,
Der zeitliche und sachliche Zusammenhang dieser vielzitierten Äußerung ist sehr klar. Es standen damals Abhöraktionen gegen Botschaften von EU-Staaten, wie auch Abhöraktionen gegen Deutsche Einrichtungen zu reden,
Das war der Punkt, den die Bundeskanzlerin ansprach. Mit streng geheimen Verschlusssachen,
die dem Untersuchungsausschuss des Deutschen Bundestages in Dokumentform vorliegen und vorgelegt wurden, hatte das nichts zu tun. Mit anderen Worten, die Kanzlerin, wusste,
zu dem Zeitpunkt, dass es diese Kooperation zwischen BND und NSA gab und hat sich in ihrer Äußerung explizit nur auf äh das Abhören von Botschaften.
Äh und äh deutsche Einrichtungen bezogen, lehrt uns,
Steffen Seibert, aber da würde ich doch ganz gerne nochmal reinhören in den original Kontext dieser Äußerung.
Die deutsche Bundeskanzlerin Angela Merkel hat sich erstmals persönlich zu den Ausspähvorwürfen geäußert. Unmittelbar vor Beginn des EU-Gipfels in Brüssel fand sie deutliche Worte.
Ich habe seitdem wir über die NSA sprechen, auch immer wieder gegenüber dem amerikanischen Präsidenten deutlich gemacht, ausspähen unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht. Das habe ich im Juni, als er in Berlin war, gesagt, im Juli und auch gestern in
Telefonat und zwar aus dem Interesse für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger in Deutschland. Da geht es nicht vordergründig um mich, sondern da geht es vor allen Dingen um alle Bürgerinnen und Bürger. Wir brauchen Vertrauen unter Verbündeten und Partnern.
Also wir hören und zwar aus dem Interesse für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger, da geht es nicht vorrangig um mich.
Naja gut, das ist ja im Prinzip auch äh.
Unserem Interesse. Also man kann es jetzt nochmal wieder so hindrehen, dass man sagt, es ist äh in unserem Interesse, dass sie nicht abgehört wird und weniger in ihrem eigenen, aber es ist schon klar, äh was da gespielt wurde, ne?
Aber auch so schwammig formuliert. Ja, also da merkt man aber auch, dass hier wirklich so die Kunst äh äh der der Politrede auch wirklich,
perfekt beherrscht, ne? Also man, selbst in dem Satz war ja irgendwie nicht so viel drin, wo man sie jetzt äh unbedingt drauf festnageln kann.
Nee, äh das das ist richtig. Es gibt da noch ein ein weiteres schönes äh Beispiel.
Aus dem Interesse, der für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger heißt ja nicht, die Bürger und Bürger werden irgendwie
abgehört oder so, ja, äh es ist ja sozusagen nicht nur mein Interesse, sondern ja, das ist ja das Interesse von allen und äh sie spricht ja auch überhaupt nichts konkret an, sonst ja. Es wird ja über die NSA geredet,
Also bloß nichts fest, auf nichts festnageln lassen können.
Ja, da gibt's noch ein noch ein schöneres, noch ein schönes Beispiel, wo auch man sich versucht, äh nicht festnagelbar zu machen,
ähm auch sehr schön zitiert in diesem äh ausführlichen Artikel der Süddeutschen,
Ähm bei der Hans-Christian Ströbele äh stellte der Regierung eine einfache Frage, ob es zutreffe, dass der Bundesnachrichtendienst aus dem Frankfurter
Glasfasernetzknoten, angezapfte Rohdaten mindestens zwischen zweitausendvier und zweitausendsieben der NSA übermittelte.
Diese Frage ist ganz einfach mit ja zu beantworten, wie wir jetzt wissen. Ist eine eine Tatsache. Ja, der hat spezifisch.
Wenn die Berichterstattung der Süddeutschen zutrifft. Siehst du jetzt.
Davon äh das stelle ich nicht in Frage, dass sie zutrifft.
Na gut, aber das ist jetzt, sagen wir mal, die einzige Quelle bisher. Es gibt jetzt noch keine.
Ja, aber die basiert ja auf.
Bestätigung.
Wie gesagt, sie basiert ja auf Unterlagen und nicht auf Spekulationen. Ja, und er bekommt die Antwort, das ist sehr schön,
Staatsminister Klaus-Dieter Fritsche aus dem Kanzleramt antwortet, der Bundesnachrichtendienst hat im angefragten Zeitraum,
Keine im Raum Frankfurt erfassten Telekommunikationsverkehre automatisiert an die NSA weitergeleitet.
Der eins, das eine Wort automatisiert, das in der Frage von äh Christian Ströbele nicht vorkam.
Setzt diesen Satz genau so, macht den so spezifisch, dass man auch heute noch behaupten kann, er wäre wahr.
Weil sie sagen, es war ja nicht automatisiert. Das ist ja irgendwie nochmal durch Filter gegangen und beim BND und es wurde nur einmal täglich automatisch übertragen, aber nicht automatisiert die Inhalte einfach so.
Das heißt, dieses schöne, überspezifische Dementi, ja, wir müssen jetzt wirklich bei jeder Äußerung der äh Regierung ähm,
jedes Scheißwort auf die Waage legen um zu schauen, äh wie es den den Sinnzusammenhang dieses Satzes irgendwie minimal äh verändert,
und uns dadurch vielleicht äh in Richtung der Wahrheit lenkt, ja?
Ja, ich ich habe dir nicht in die Fresse geschlagen, während ich ein blaues T-Shirt trug.
Genau, ja.
Die NSA hat die so schließt auch der der Artikel der süddeutschen ähm automatisiert bekam die NSA keine Daten aus Frankfurt, sie wurden freiwillig vom BND übergeben,
Ja, also ähm ich finde das, wie gesagt, es ist eine,
bis auf die technischen Zusammenhänge oder technischen Details und die politischen Zusammenhänge, die da nochmal drin aufgerollt sind, keine.
Nichts nichts, was wir nicht vorher gewusst hätten und was nicht eigentlich auch offensichtlich war.
Hm. Ja, das ist ähm.
Aber es ist natürlich umso wichtiger oder umso schöner, dass das jetzt äh vor diesem Hintergrund der der Jahre oder des Jahres Äußerungen zu diesem Thema äh herauskommt, ne.
Meine, was ist denn sozusagen die Gesamtsituation, die sich daraus jetzt eigentlich zusammenbauen lässt?
Zweitausendeins, Nine Eleven, die Amerikaner drehen irgendwie komplett frei, was so Überwachungsmaßnahmen betrifft, sowohl in den USA. Das eigene Volk und auch so äh auf die
digitalen Ebene wird irgendwie alles nochmal so auf elf gedreht. Und,
Teil davon ist, dass große Solidarität eingeklagt wird, dass wahrscheinlich weltweit. Wer immer gerne dabei war, sind die Five Eyes, also Kanada, UK, äh Neuseeland,
ähm ah okay, Leute und USA, äh wer war noch mal der Fünfte?
UK USA, Neuseeland, Australien.
Australien natürlich.
Und dann habe ich aber jetzt noch den Fünften weggelassen.
Nee, also Australien, Neuseeland, UK, Kanada, genau und USA. So,
Die waren ja sozusagen Gewehr bei Fuß und das war ja schon immer so und da äh dürfte wahrscheinlich der der Datenfluss immer maximal gewesen sein, nur dass eben jetzt andere Länder auch noch interessant ist, weil
Im Übrigen ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar, da haben wir auch relativ wenig Erkenntnisse oder zumindest äh tauchen bei uns relativ wenig Nachrichten äh auf, was so zum Beispiel die Rolle von Frankreich betrifft. Also es gab ja da auch schon einzelne. Wäre auch nochmal interessant, aber Deutschland ist natürlich da
ganz vorne und die von dir schon erwähnte, die uneingeschränkte Solidarität, die Schröder ausgesprochen hat, auch wenn er dann.
Wiederhole, uneingeschränkt Solidarität.
Ja, ja. Was ja da nicht ganz so uneingeschränkt war in der Folge, äh mit dem Irak-Krieg. Mark nun dazu geführt haben, dass man dann eben auch so auf digitaler Ebene äh zugestimmt hat und gesagt hat, okay ja, ihr dürft jetzt hier mal,
abhorchen, sprich irgendwie gibt's eine Leitung zum BND, irgendwie sind die Daten da hinbekommen, wahrscheinlich nicht automatisiert, vermutlich muss da irgendwie einmal am Tag irgendwie mal so wie bei Lost irgendwie auf eine Taste drücken,
damit dieser Datenfluss auch weiterhin läuft und nicht als automatisiert bezeichnet werden kann. Irgendwie sowas und,
ja, dieser Filter ist vermutlich Quatsch. Ja, also es klingt für mich so ein bisschen nach so einem fake Filter.
Ja, wir haben da auch einen Filter und der filtert da irgendwas. So,
und schon hatte die NSA einfach den Zugriff auf das deutsche Internet an einer wichtigen Stelle. Wobei das ja äh sicherlich nochmal wert ist, zu betonen,
Die Ezix ist zwar der größte Internetknoten in Deutschland,
Und auch ein ähm wie soll ich sagen, also ein ein wichtiger Austauschpunkt, aber das schließt ja so ein bisschen die Telekom etwas aus.
Die Telekom an der Stelle nicht so in dem Maße piert, wie es eben alle anderen tun. Also alle außer der Telekom kommunizieren vor allem über das Diäzex.
Ja, die Telekom hat nur das, dass die Leitung nachgelegt.
Ja, ja, ebenso und das ist man kann sich aber jetzt, wenn man jetzt mal äh eins und eins zusammenzählt, kann das ja eigentlich auch nur bedeuten, dass einfach ein Äquivalenter Zugriff eigentlich auch äh im Telekom-Netz existieren müsste, um das,
Puzzle zu vervollständigen.
Selbstverständlich, auch da haben wir ja also es geht, wir haben ja schon die äh die Meldung über ähm ähm das war ja auch erst wieder vor ein paar Wochen, dass die NSA im Telekom-Netz drin säße
ja
ähm wo dann die Telekom irgendwie sagt, ja, hm, haben wir irgendwie nicht feststellen können. Ja, natürlich nicht, weil sie das nutzen, was sowieso da ist. Also das ist ähm.
Nochmal, wenn du ein Netz mit einer Loveful Intersep Schnittstelle hast.
Dann heckst du natürlich die Lorfor Intercept-Schnittstelle,
du kriegst diese Datenmengen nicht sinnvoll daraus und vernünftig gefiltert an Ort und Stelle, indem du da irgendwelche Büchsen häckst. So, es muss ein riesiger Datenstrom,
aus diesem aus diesem Kern, aus diesem Netz, wo auch immer zu dir. Und der kommt dann nicht einfach zu dir, äh indem du da was heckst und keiner merkt das.
So, das wir reden davon irgendwie riesigen Datenmengen und die gehen natürlich nur also die kriegst du dann nur über gesonderte Leitungen irgendwie raus.
Also.
Ja und so heißt es, dass dann quasi auch der BND an der Stelle, alle Schnittstellen einfach so bei DeFAld zum voll schnorcheln, freischaltet.
Keinem Zeitpunkt automatisiert.
Nee, nee, klar, also einmal am Tag muss man halt die Taste drücken.
Also ich kann mir kein ähm ich kann mir keinen anderen ähm,
sinnvollen Weg vorstellen, der,
Massenüberwachung in diesem Ausmaß überhaupt ermöglichen würde. Also es kann, äh, das habe ich ja oft, wie gesagt, schon schon, äh, sehr viel früher dazu gesagt. Es kann nicht passieren, ohne, dass die Deutschen Dienste das,
mitbekommen oder ermöglichen. Es geht einfach nicht. Also weißt du, wenn ich dem wenn ich im,
stell dir mal vor, ich stell jetzt in den Dezixen Gerät, was,
An einem Monitoringport hängt und all das, was da rauskommt, nochmal äh weiterschickt. Das müsste ja bedeuten, dass der gesamte Gebäudedezix nur.
Maximal fünfzig Prozent seiner Kapazität tatsächlich nutzt. Was eventuell stimmt, aber sie würden halt merken, wenn sich ihre Belastung auf einmal um einhundert äh um einhundert Prozent erhöht,
Ja also du kriegst diese Daten dann nicht raus, ohne dass es jemandem auffällt. Es sei denn, du nutzt einen Kanal, der ohnehin schon da ist und das ist eben der ähm,
der des Lochvol Interset. Und der wiederum ist ja so angelegt, ähm hat hatten wir glaube ich auch schon mal besprochen, dass du eben diese Sammelstelle vor Ort hast.
Damit die Mitarbeiter des,
Betroffenen äh der betroffenen Infrastruktur nicht sehen, was du ablauscht oder nicht. Es wäre ja, wie gesagt, eine Katastrophe, wenn die Dezix-Mitarbeiter ähm quasi,
Die Konfigurationen oder die Such äh Einstellungen für die für den BND oder für die NSA machen würden.
Würden ja sofort anfangen, das äh irgendwie zu Geld zu machen, indem sie halt Leute waren oder äh über diese Überwachungsmaßnahmen manipulieren oder so.
Hm. Die fünfzig Prozentschwelle gilt ja auch nach deiner eigenen Aussage jetzt so nicht. Also wenn man jetzt mal den replizierbaren Datenverkehr abzieht, dann landet man irgendwie nicht bei fünfzig.
Ja, das stimmt. Nee, dann bist du bei zehn, aber du kriegst sie trotzdem da nicht raus. Also das sind wichtig.
Es ist halt immer noch immer noch sehr, sehr, sehr viel, ne.
Und vor allem ähm,
Grade jetzt bei, als es vor ein paar Wochen um die Telekom ging, die haben ja dann auch geschaut, die sind ja losgegangen und haben sich ihre ähm,
haben sich ihre Netze nochmal angeschaut und haben gesagt, haben wir irgendwo einen anscheinend für äh Compromis fliegen hier irgendwo äh Daten raus, die wir ähm.
Ja, es macht vor allem so den Eindruck, als ob Frank-Walter Steinmeier an der Stelle derjenige ist, der es quasi letztlich autorisiert hat, ja? Sicherlich nicht, ähm.
Wie soll ich sagen? Weil er es jetzt mal persönlich geil fand so. Das ist jetzt nicht so ein so ein Eigenlauf, sondern quasi einfach Quaabend
weil es äh offensichtlich ja äh Staatsraison zu sein schien oder immer noch ist, ja, also diese Kooperation wurde einfach als wichtig äh erachtet
und wurde einfach äh genehmigt und die Aussage, dass es dann vor allem nicht dem G zehn der G zehn Kommission vorgelegt wird, was ja nun an sich nicht gerade jetzt besonders
Offenherziger äh Club ist, was vier Mitglieder sind da äh drin. Ähm.
Sind zehn Leute.
Vier würde mich wundern, weil es äh das würde ja noch nicht mal die Fraktion äh die die Parteien äh widerspiegeln.
Ähm na, das sind fünf. Also es ist irgendwie.
Ein CDU-Mensch, Rechtsanwalt, Andreas Schmidt, äh stellvertretender Vorsitzender Berthold Huber, Frank Hoffmann, SPD, äh Ver.
Nee, du hast Recht, also aktuell sind.
Mauer. Also es gibt dann immer noch es gibt immer noch Vertreter, also im Prinzip sind's acht Leute, ne. Ähm.
Interessanterweise diese werden vertreten von NN. Was heißt denn das?
Hier reichen wieder die Initialen oder was? Wolfgang, CSU, Hartmann und dann die Hallina äh warf zehn Jahre,
dass die Kommission, die man quasi über solche Abhörmaßnahmen im Prinzip in Kenntnis äh setzen muss, die also auf Basis dieses G zehn Gesetzes
ähm zur Beschränkung des Brief, Post und Fernmeldegeheimnisses, was ja eigentlich, ne, eigentlich äh ja gilt, aber es gibt halt eine
Beschränkungen und um das eben zu überwachen oder zu kontrollieren, gibt's eben diese G zehn Kommission. Und wenn jetzt halt,
so ein massive Schnorchelaktion schlicht und ergreifend nicht an die G zehn weitergeleitet wird, weil ist ja nicht so wichtig, weil da wird ja nicht abgehört, sondern da wird ja nur ausgeleitet, ja?
Dann ist das eigentlich schon ein echter Skandal.
Dann ist das ein ähm ja, das ist nicht nur ein Skandal, das ist eben Verstoß gegen das G zehn Gesetz und damit ein Verstoß gegen das Grundgesetz.
Also ultimativ ist es, ja, also klar ein ein spezifischer Verfassungsbruch
Brief und Fernmeldegeheimnisses, denn alles jeder äh jede Verletzung, das Brief- und Fernwäldegeheimnis muss eben von diesem G zehn Gesetz gedeckt sein.
Eine derartige Ausweitung von Daten ist es nicht. Ganz einfach.
Das Merkwürdige ist hier, ich habe gerade mal aus dem Fenster geguckt, Linos und äh es brennt noch keine Mülltonnen.
Ja. Immer noch nicht.
Es ist äh unglaublich. Ja, ja.
Es ist unglaublich, ja. Wir lassen das alles mit uns machen. Das ist ähm.
Das ist echt interessant. Also ähm es geschieht ja zu unserem eigenen Schutz.
Genau. Gegen Terror. Damit wir hier nicht alle enthauptet werden. Haben wir es erstmal hier mit dem Thema, ich glaube sehr viel mehr kann man da jetzt nicht mehr zu sagen, oder?
Nee, man kann da jetzt.
Wie gesagt, also ähm es ist Skandal. Ist ein Skandal und äh es scheint halt auch wieder nicht äh.
Zu werden in dem Maße.
Ja, äh sehr viel besser äh reflektiert wird ähm dafür, der doch äh eher unterhaltsame Disput zwischen der VG Media
Google und auch dem Bundeskartellamt, da geht ja der Ball äh in letzter Zeit häufiger hin und her. Wir erinnern uns, Leistungsschutzrecht wurde von ähm ja einer Springer geführten Koalition,
durchgesetzt.
Von einer springergeführten Koalition.
Ja. Ach so, ich.
Ach so, ich dachte ich dachte, du meinst die Regierungskoali.
Nee, das hatte ich jetzt nicht so. Ich meinte eher so eine Koalition von Verlagen, aber man kann das jetzt auch mal frei interpretieren. Und ähm die äh ja, die Regierungskoalition hat das ja dann noch,
durchgesetzt so unter äh dem Erstaunen und und und offenen offenstehenden Mündern der äh sogenannten Netz Netzgemeinde,
und ähm ja und jüngst äh
den Versuch, dieses Leistungsschutzrecht dann auch mal in Stellung äh zu bringen, dann äh hat sich das Ganze in Form der VG Media, wo halt viele Verlage, die große Fans von diesem Leistungsschutzrecht zusammengeschlossen sind
sich dann sozusagen erstmal ja versucht da mit einer Klage gegen äh Google durchzusetzen. Die kam dann aber nicht so weit, weil ähm,
ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, in welchem Gericht wurde das abgelehnt? Ja, das ist mal das wieder unsere da ist sie wieder, unsere äh äh Jura
Schwäche, wie auch immer, diese Klage wurde dann aber wirklich mit Kopfschütteln abgelehnt.
Es war kein Gericht, es war die äh das Kartellamt.
Also es war auch schon äh genau das Kartell ab, natürlich, das Kartellamt äh hat sich quasi dieser Beschwerde da nicht wirklich anschließen können, hat einfach gesagt, wovon redet ihr eigentlich? So.
Und hat ja noch gesagt so, pass mal auf, äh wenn ihr hier mit Marktmacht kommt, dann müssen wir irgendwann, äh wenn ihr uns weiter auf den Sack geht, werden wir mal prüfen, ob ihr nicht im Kartell seid. Ja, ähm.
Ist doch super.
Würden jetzt halt, jetzt halt Google äh angekündigt und hat gesagt, na ja.
Da gibt's ja dieses.
Wir haben dieses, wir haben dieses Leistungsschutzrecht mal gelesen und wir müssen ähm,
quasi wir sind entweder also wir dürfen ohne deren Zustimmung keine Bilder oder Textpassagen übernehmen.
Also machen wir das jetzt.
Also machen wir es auch nicht, weil sie haben ja explizit gesagt, dass sie auf der auf der Wahrnehmung ihres Leistungsschutzrechtes bestehen. Insofern wenn wir nicht wollen, dass die uns verklagen,
dann müssen wir eben äh Snippets und Thumbnails aller Verlage, die in der VG Media äh organisiert sind, aus unseren äh Angeboten heraushalten. Das heißt, wir zeigen nur noch den Seitentitel an, ja?
So viel dürfen wir.
Auch so, was wahrscheinlich auch so viel bedeutet bei, bei News Google, also wir werden das ja ab morgen sehen, also angekündigt ist es für den neunten Oktober, äh wenn man sich halt so das Seitenlayout anschaut so, dann ist natürlich klar, der top gelistete Artikel dürfte mit,
weiß ich, was da die Zahlen sind, aber ich würde mal sagen, so siebzig bis achtzig Prozent aller Klicks dürften wahrscheinlich auf diesen ersten gehen. Ja, weil der irgendwie als,
Am relevantesten angesehen wird. Da drunter sind dann ja immer noch andere gelistet mit nur dem Titel, ohne Snippets, ohne Bilder. Sprich.
Nicht nicht nur das keine äh dabei rauskommen werden. Das wird wahrscheinlich bedeuten, dass die einfach niemals auf Platz eins sind. Ja. Ja?
Also was weiß ich,
Gestern war da noch Welt DE und ähnliche Vertreter aus der Springer Verlagslandschaft, die da sehr wohl ähm der Top-Link waren für ein jeweiliges Thema und das ähm
gut wird sich dann morgen zeigen, aber ich vermute mal, das ist schon eine ganz nennenswerte äh Degradierung.
Und selbst wenn sie Erster wären, wäre halt unten drunter einer mit einem schönen Bild und einer großen, großen Ausschnitt, äh der dann halt größer wirkt. Also ähm.
Was Google da macht, ist, sie halten sich an das Gesetz, dass die Verlage, die den Leistungsschutz, der dieses Leistungsschutzrecht haben wollten, sich genauso geschrieben haben. Das ist die logische Konsequenz,
ja? Und jetzt sagt die Folge Media, ja aber ähm Moment, jetzt sind wir ja benachteiligt,
gegenüber den Verlagen, die das Leistungsschutzrecht nicht in Anspruch nehmen. Und geht dann wieder zum Bundeskartellamt,
und sagt, ey wir haben hier ein Recht, was wir Google nicht einräumen und deswegen verzichtet Google darauf,
Dieses Recht wahrzunehmen, weil sie's, weil wir's ihnen nicht geben. Und wir haben jetzt festgestellt, dadurch werden wir benachteiligt,
Ähm,
Und das Bundeskartellamt sagt, na ja, äh aus dem Kartellrecht lässt sich aber jetzt keine Verpflichtung ableiten, dass Betreiber von Suchmaschinen Textausschnitte entgeltlich erwerben müssen.
So Andreas Mund, der Chef der äh Behörde. Äh also der des Bundeskartellamts. Ja, natürlich nicht. Aber.
Da wir sind ja wieder bei dem alten, bei dem alten Aspekt. Google hat eben fünfundneunzig Prozent Marktanteil und ähm,
in einem sehr, sehr köstlichen Interview mit dem äh Deutschlandradiok Kultur. Ähm hat dann auch äh Maren Ruhfuß äh von der VG Media äh gesagt, dass,
ihr das natürlich am Arsch vorbeigeht, wenn sie bei äh
bei der Telekom oder bei Web DE mit ihren unter oder maximal ein Prozent Marktanteil in den Suchergebnissen nicht mehr auftauchen. Aber Google hat eben fünfundneunzig Prozent und da ist das jetzt entwickelt sich dieses ähm Leistungsschutzrecht zu einem
Erschuss in den Fuß. Äh dieses Interview ist großartig. Es zeigt also ähm.
Ich habe schon lange nicht mehr so ein geeier gehört.
Na, die arme Frau, ja, ich meine, die hat ja so Geschäftsführer. Ich dachte Sprecherin.
Ist die Geschäftsführerin. Nein, nein, also vielleicht ist ja auch die Sprecherin, aber sie ist auf jeden Fall äh die Geschäftsführerin, also einer von zweien.
Sie sie hat da wirklich ähm große Mühe.
Das Rudern, sie ruderte.
Noch irgendwie ein ein sinnvolles Argument äh äh vorzubringen und ähm
das ist natürlich, das ist eigentlich schade, weil oder oder das das zeigt, dass es da auf Wirklichkeit gibt. Ja, sie sagt dann also, ja
die Wahrnehmung des Leistungsschutzrechtes ist natürlich eine unternehmerische Entscheidung der Verlage mit anderen Worten was kann ich dafür, dass die so doof sind?
Aber ich muss das jetzt hier irgendwie durchrocken, das ist halt mein Job, ja? Und äh.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass sie diese Job jetzt nicht mehr so lange äh machen wird. Entweder weil die Verlage sich jemanden versuchen, jemanden zu finden,
der irgendwie.
Keine Probleme damit hat, argumentationsfrei in der Öffentlichkeit zu.
Sie werden halt jemanden suchen, der ähm in seiner Argumentation,
von der konkreten Frage weggeht und sich auf ähm zentrale moralische äh Prinzipien beruft. Und Sätze, die den jeder zustimmen würde,
Ja, das versucht sie auch. Das kriegt sie nicht so gut hin. Also das ist äh also du brauchst halt jemanden, der dann mehr das kann, es kann doch nicht sein.
Man wird auch nochmal sagen dürfen.
Man wird so wir können doch nicht akzeptieren,
Ja, also da da werden da werden wir noch ein paar Sachen eingefallen, die man ähm besser hätte sagen können und äh um dafür für diesen Unsinn zu argumentieren. Aber es ist sehr schön, dass halt selbst die Leute, die sich tagtäglich,
damit beschäftigen, dass die auch nicht in der Lage sind, auch nur irgendwie sinnvolles Argument dafür vorzubringen,
Das ist schon sehr schön. Was sie also jetzt will, ist offenkundig, dass Google News den anderen Verlagen, nämlich denen, die auf ihr ähm Leistungsschutzrecht äh.
Nicht äh bestehen, denen auch noch,
irgendwie was weiß ich, die die Snippets wegnimmt, ja? Aber das ist, wie gesagt, also sie müssen halt dieses äh diesen äh dieses Gesetz halt lesen, was sie da geschrieben haben, ja?
Habe es doch selber geschrieben.
Selber geschrieben und der deswegen finde ich auch den den Titel von Stefan Niger, der sagt, also da hätten wir alles nicht mehr reden müssen, äh Verlage empört. Jetzt will Google nicht mal mehr ihr Recht verletzen.
Ja, damit hat er Recht.
Das ist so auf dem Punkt. Es ist wirklich großartig. Ich meine äh ich ich freue mich irgendwie extrem, weil diese diese lächerliche ich weiß nicht, als wir hier das erste Mal über Leistungsschutzrecht diskutiert haben, als das überhaupt aufkommt. So, ich meine, das war doch einfach,
Einhelliges Kopfschütteln. Es war einfach immer so ein das ist so stupid, das ist so dermaßen bekloppt und durfte das kann einfach nicht sein, dass das keiner merkt,
So. Aber es wurde dann halt einfach durchgesetzt und es ist ein schönes Beispiel,
denke ich, wo einfach die Angst vor diesen Verlagsimperien in der in der Politik,
Also man könnte man kann's als Angst bezahlen, man kann auch Kurhandel unterstellen, was weiß ich. Auf jeden Fall äh
es zeigt auf jeden Fall, dass da, dass da an der Stelle keine keine wirkliche politische Ratio noch äh herler Lage war, sondern dass es hier einfach nur so ein ist, so ah ihr wollt das, ja okay, alles klar, machen wir mal
seht zu, dass ihr ansonsten auf Linie bleibt sonst, na?
Na ja, aber das haben wir ja schon alles zu Genüge diskutiert, insofern äh.
Insofern war das natürlich ein sehr billiger Kauf für äh die Politik. Ja, also wir haben jetzt hier wie so ein so ein Recht beschlossen, was am Ende äh ein zahnloser Tiger ist.
Nee, ist es nicht, also es wird, das ist ja kein zahnloser Tiger. Du siehst, das ist halt grade maximal zum Schaden der Verlage ausgelegt wird. Ich fänd's halt geil, wenn die sich vielleicht demnächst dafür anstrengen, das wieder loszuwerden.
Das kann eigentlich ja.
Nee, werden sie natürlich nicht. Also sie werden halt ähm es war klar und das haben wir ja auch, also deswegen will ich das Thema jetzt auch echt mal langsam abschneiden. Äh wir haben.
Damals gesagt, es, dass die Linie der Verlage vor diesem Gesetz nur sein könnte, dass sie sich auf Kartell äh berufen werden. Das war von vorneherein klar.
Und ähm das Bundeskartelleamt ist eben in der momentanen Besetzung äh davon nicht zu überzeugen. Ja, das heißt, dass ähm.
Man kann jetzt natürlich noch darauf hoffen, dass das Bundeskartellamt irgendwie anders besetzt wird. Ähm aber quasi, dass der Business Case, den sie da aufgemacht haben,
ist äh,
Erstmal weg, ja? Dass das Geld ist verbrannt. Und das da wird's jetzt auch keinen anderen Weg mehr geben. Außerhalb des Übliche, ne, Attentat und äh politischen Neubesetzung oder sowas. Das wären halt jetzt noch die schnellen Wege.
Äh die ich dafür sehe
Und da kann man sich natürlich auch als äh einfach mal genüsslich zurücklehnen und sich das sechs Minuten Interview anhören und ein bisschen feixen.
Ja und das war ja noch dazu. Also.
Ja, siehst du, steht.
Wäre sonst nicht so viel zu lachen, also von daher.
Ja, die so kommen wir, kommen wir weiter.
Ja, wir kommen weiter. Äh die neuen EU-Kommissare sind ja noch nicht bestätigt. Da muss ja noch das äh Europäische Parlament,
zustimmen und wird sicherlich den ein oder anderen zu Fall bringen nichtsdestotrotz sind die wie sagt man die,
geschlagenen Kommissare äh schon dabei, sich auch öffentlich zu äußern.
Nicht nur öffentlich, die werden ja auch in diesen Hearings, die da jetzt alle gerade stattfinden, eben ja, gegrillt. Da gibt's dieses schöne äh Situation, wo ähm,
wo Martin Sonneborn dann den den Oettinger befragt, äh wie den Öttinger verhindern möchte, äh
oder wie Oettinger sicherstellen wird, dass das Internet nicht vergessen wird, dass er irgendwie besoffen rumgefahren ist, den den Nazi-Filginger da als Widerstandskämpfer bezeichnet hat und so ihn mit seinen ganzen ähm,
politischen äh Verfehlung konfrontiert. Da haben sich viele jetzt sehr drüber gefreut und so, hä, Sonne bohren, geil, geil, geil. Ich fand aber die die Antwort von Öttinger war da schon sehr äh abgebrüht. Der hat das schon, der hat die Situation schon gut gemeistert, ja.
Er war souverän.
Ähm und da sind also jetzt diese ganzen Heerings und da gibt es also jetzt den Dimitris Avramo Poulus, Polos,
Avramapoll-Luss, Avramopoulos.
Uss. Mhm. Los, aber. Opulus, Los. Ja, los, los, das ist ja alles.
Dimitris Avramopoulos und das soll der Kommissar für Migration und Innenpolitik werden, der,
ein wahrer Sympath. Du musst dir mal das Foto von dem anschauen
scheidende griechische Verteidigungsminister und will jetzt der der EU Minister für Migration und Innenpolitik werden, ja? Also du weißt, was das wenn du in diesem Bereichen ähm,
Leidenschaft, politische Leidenschaft entwickelst, ja, dann äh weißt du Bescheid, Westgeistes Kind du bist, ne?
Ähm ich kann meinen, da gibt's schönere Fotos, als auf der auf der Wikipedia.
Ein schönes Foto mit Putin. Wobei das halt ja nichts aus.
Schau mal hier noch, was wir da so für Bilder haben, wo wir wo haben, also.
Ja, ich will dem jetzt nicht irgendeinen äh Zug unterstellen, äh was halt so ein bisschen beunruhigender ist, dass er äh der Meinung ist, ja, man müsse ja nochmal bei der Vorratsdatenspeicherung
nochmal äh da neue Wege äh gehen und die das äh EuGH äh Urteil zur Vorratsdatenspeicherung, was wir ja generell hier als äh Begräbnis äh der Vorratsdatenspeicherung weitgehend äh interpretieren,
soll ja sozusagen dann mal so die Basis sein. Eines neuen äh Entwurfs, weil ja, es kann ja nicht sein und so, ne,
das jetzt hier so Terrorismus und schwere Feuer brechen und Cyber Crime. Äh wie sagt der so schön unter voller Beachtung des Rechts äh
auf Privatsphäre äh nicht mehr bekämpft werden äh könnte, so da muss man doch mal was machen.
Sie wollen das Gleiche tun ähm was in Deutschland ja auch die ganze Zeit noch oder er möchte das Gleiche tun, was in Deutschland ja auch die ganze Zeit noch auf der Kippe steht, nämlich ähm,
dass das äh Urteil des des obersten Gerichtshofes in diesem Fall äh als Vorlage nehmen für ein Gesetz,
dass ähm die Kritikpunkte ausräumt und dadurch dazu führt, dass äh es nicht mehr von diesem oberen Gericht äh einkassiert werden kann. Das war ja auch äh in Deutschland ist in der Deutschland nach wie vor auch das Ziel.
Ähm nur dass man da gesagt hat, okay, wir warten noch auf das EuGH-Urteil, bevor wir das ganze Papier jetzt irgendwie äh von unseren von unseren äh Beratern äh schreiben lassen. Und dann das das Projekt nochmal in Auftrag geben müssen,
weil sich der die Gesetz die ähm höchstinstanzliche äh Rechtsprechung,
da nochmal geändert hat und wir müssen noch einen anderen Aspekt beachten, ja? Aber das heißt, die die wollen also jetzt natürlich Experten darauf loslassen, die äh dass diese Richtlinie so formulieren.
Äh dass sie eben nicht mehr äh unter diese Kritikpunkte fällt.
Das wird also der, das König dieser äh Mann schon an. Ähm bevor er überhaupt im Amt ist. Ähm,
Das Urteil war im April diesen Jahres und ähm,
zuständig war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt noch die jetzt äh scheidende äh Cecilia Mainström und die hat sich eben in Anbetracht der des Endes ihrer Amtszeit dann gesagt okay komm,
in den paar Monaten mache ich das Fass jetzt nicht mehr auf, das überlasse ich meinem Nachfolger und entsprechend ähm wird das jetzt auch besetzt.
Dimitris Avramopoulos. Ja, es gab dann noch oder es gibt jetzt einen ähm,
Mit einer Aktion von äh Campact,
Ich lehne eine Anlass- und Verdachtsunabhängige Vorratsdatenspeicherung ab. Es gab auch eine Aktion von ähm ich glaube Digitalcourage und digitaler Gesellschaft und wen sehe ich da noch im Bild?
Äh nee, keiner von, das war das da gab's noch ein größeres Bild, genau. Also die Etri-Leute, sich da jemand von Edri, warum san die denn nicht da?
Doch, doch. Also ähm es gab dann eine äh eine Aktion nochmal einen Auftakt äh zu dieser dieser Aktion ähm.
Jan-Philipp Albrecht war auch nochmal da und da haben sie dann dem äh,
Dimitris Avramopoulos, ein gold gerahmtes Bild mit einem Auszug aus dem Urteil des äh Europäischen Gerichtshofs gegen die Vorratsdatenspeicherung überreicht. Ja, sie haben diese Gold gerahmt ähm.
Den, den, den, die,
die Grundrechtsbasierte Entscheidung da äh gegeben in der Hoffnung, dass er äh plötzlich, nachdem er jahrelang sich mit Verteidigung Migrationsabwehr und Innenpolitik auseinandergesetzt hat und das auch in Zukunft tun möchte.
Ähm irgendwie noch seine Stimmung zu ändern, ja? Und das wird aber wahrscheinlich ähm.
Der soll erstmal durchkommen, ne? Also.
Es zeigt, naja äh es zeigt aber, dass was ich dann immer in so fatalistischen Stunden äh beklage, dass wir keine.
Sie keine endgültigen Siege zu erlangen scheinen. Diese Themen bleiben einfach da. Äh Sascha Lobo hatte das ja auch schon mal sehr trefflich als äh diese Themen als äh Zombies bezeichnet.
Die äh dann immer wieder aufstehen, ja, den schlägst du, die schlägst du kaputt und dann kommen die halt wieder äh und findet sich immer nützlicher Depp. Ähm.
Und es wäre halt schön, wenn das irgendwann mal aufhören würde. Aber ähm.
Vielleicht äh sind ja auch seine äh Bemühungen dann nicht ähm von Erfolg gekrönt. Darauf bleibt ja noch zu hoffen.
So, dann gibt's noch eine Meldung aus den USA, Twitter.
Genau, Twitter.
Mal wieder den Klageweg an oder überhaupt erstmal äh und zwar bezieht sich das auf den ähm.
Bericht, den sie im April diesen Jahres verfasst haben und den haben sie ähm dann
dem
FBI. Äh dem Aterny General, der äh United States, dem Justiz äh Ministerium vorgelegt und haben gesagt, hier folgenden Transparenzbericht über eure Aktivitäten,
möchten wir gerne veröffentlichen. Und zwar möchten wir darin sowas machen, wie Zahlen nennen, dass wir sagen, wir haben so und so viele Anfragen bekommen äh und denen entsprochen, wie es ja zum Beispiel Google auch äh,
über die über viele Länder getan hat, wie wir das auch vor ein paar Monaten dann von ich meine mich zu erinnern der Deutschen Telekom. Und Vodafone äh veröffentlicht äh gesehen haben, wo also gesagt wurde.
Von Apple gab's das auch, ähm die dann irgendwie gesagt haben, Folgendes ist der, der Stand der Dinge bei uns.
Wobei sie es immer in so einem Range anhaben angeben müssen so. Also es waren nicht mehr als ein also von null bis äh.
Und dann bis zu tausendneunundneunzig oder so. Ähm,
Und jetzt hat Twitter also einen eigenen Transparenzbericht verfasst, der sich offensichtlich nicht an diese Vorgaben hält und hat neun Monate lang
fünf Monate lang keine Antwort bekommen und dann irgendwie Anfang September erfahren, da wurde kam dann offensichtlich so ein Einzeiler bekommen. Ja die Information in eurem Transparenzbericht ist leider Klasse Fight und deswegen dürft ihr die nicht veröffentlichen.
Und die Basis äh für diese Anfragen
über die sie da gerne Transparenz geben würden. Wie gesagt, da geht's nur um die Zahl, nicht um die Betroffenen, würde ich mal vermuten. Äh ist der Foren Intelligence Valence Act, also der fieser und die National Security Letters, also die Briefe
mit dem Gag Order, wo also drin steht. Hallo, gib uns folgende Information und sprich mit niemandem darüber.
Ähm auch das äh eine äh Praxis, die wir hier schon häufiger beleuchtet haben. Ich verweise da immer wieder auf den äh großartigen Vortrag von Nic Maril beim siebenundzwanzig C drei, wenn ich mich nicht täusche,
ähm wo es um um diese Gag-Orders ging. Wir erinnern uns, dass äh Twitter da auch äh eine,
seine Rechtsabteilung bemüht hat, als es um die Daten von Jacob Apple-Baum, Birgit hier ähm Julien Assange und äh Rob Gongrip ging,
äh wo wir auch dann diesen Brief veröffentlicht gesehen haben und gemerkt haben, dass es äh sich dabei um einen Vordruck handelt, in dem auch Abrechnungsformalitäten und so weiter abgefragt werden, die natürlich bei äh Twitter gar nicht gibt. Ähm.
Rede kurzer Sinn. Twitter würde diesen Transparenzreport gerne veröffentlichen und wir hat da jetzt auf Basis des fieser ähm,
Eine Absage erteilt bekommen und setzt sich dagegen mit einer Klage gegen den, dass äh,
Justizministerium, das FBI, ähm,
zur Wehr und möchte diese Regelung kippen. Und zwar begründen sie das mit, dass diese Einschränkungen eine ähm,
Der Satz ist so lang. Eine äh Diskriminierung äh darstellen und Twitters Recht auf freie Äußerungen,
untergraben insbesondere in einem Bereich der einer globale öffentliche Sorge betrifft.
Und sie sagen, und das äh erste Amament ähm gibt uns das Recht, diese Sorgen unserer Nutzer zu adressieren.
Und ihnen eine vollständige Übersicht,
Über den eingeschränkten, über das eingeschränkte Ausmaß der äh der Überwachung durch das durch die US-Regierung zu zeigen. Das heißt, sie sagen also ne ähm.
Selbst in der, in der Klagebegründung sagen sie, ja ähm,
Es zeigt doch, dass dass Twitter eben nicht voll überwacht ist, sondern dass es sehr eingeschränkt ist. Und deswegen ist es für uns von äh von finanziellen Vorteil
dieses Vertrauen der Nutzer wieder zu erlangen und für die US-Regierung nicht von Nachteil, wenn wir diese Anonymisierte Veröffentlichung,
machen. Und wir möchten eben veröffentlichen, welche Arten von legalen,
Prozessen wir empfangen haben, ja? Also ob das jetzt vom FBI kam, äh oder ob das jetzt von so und so kam und mit einem Gag-Order versehen war und letztendlich richten sie sich da erneut gegen diese,
Gag Orders.
Twitter ist ja auch nicht ganz alleine, also ich habe ähm vermehrt den Eindruck, dass so das komplette Silicon Valley eigentlich,
das so richtig
richtig furchtbar und schlimm findet, so ist ja auch ganz klar, denen geht halt potenziell da auch äh eine Menge Einnahmen und Einfluss äh verloren, ja, also allein die Auswirkungen so im Cloud-Markt, äh Business-Cloud-Markt sind sicherlich
ganz äh nachhaltig beziehungsweise hat natürlich Twitter auch da einfach einen Ruf zu verlieren, zumal sie ja auch immer so ein bisschen als nicht wahr, so über die Jahre äh äh so als,
soll ich sagen? Äh gehandelt wurden, ist teilweise sicherlich auch immer noch sind, ne? Nur dass natürlich diese ganze äh Überwachungsgeschichte und Durchreichung insbesondere privater Nachrichten für sie einfach ja,
weiß ich nicht, existenziell sein kann auch. Aber zumindest,
Ganz wesentlichen ihr in ihr Business reinschneit, mit Apple nicht anders und auch Google hat natürlich einen Ruf zu verlieren,
Äh und das ist natürlich sehr interessant, wie kann sich eigentlich äh der Staat,
USA, das Ganze äh Regierungsgefüge durchsetzen, wenn eine der potentesten äh,
Abteilungen der Wirtschaft auf der Matte steht und sagt, hör mal, so nicht.
Ja, ähm.
Ich habe wir hatten das ja sogar mal äh ausnahmsweise mal angekündigt. Ich habe mich da am Montag ähm,
bei der Bundeszentrale für politische Bildung drüber unterhalten.
Insbesondere also da ging's weniger um staatliche Überwachung, äh sondern über die um die ähm.
Profilbildung und letztendlich auch Überwachung, die eben von so Akteuren wie äh Google, Facebook und Werbenetzwerken im Internet ausgeht. Ähm.
Es ist net, es ist ein interessanter Aspekt, dass wir im Moment offenbar bereit sind, all diese Informationen,
Facebook oder Google zu geben über uns ja? Mein Facebook lässt dich nicht los, sie sind in jede scheiß Internetseite die du besuchst eingebunden und wissen dass du da gerade bist,
und du trägst du du regelst deine private Kommunikation über irgendwelche Facebook-Nachrichten durch sie? Sie haben dein WhatsApp
auch noch mit in in ihrer Datenbasis, das heißt, du du
gibst du gibst dich freiwillig einer Vollüberwachung durch äh Facebook hin und das kleine bisschen Restemail und Google, was du noch machst, das gibst du halt googlen, ja? Und die haben dadurch eine,
eine in eine noch nie dagewesene,
Macht in der Überwachung der Menschheit. Und die ist immer noch größer, würde ich jetzt mal so vermuten,
und umfassender als die Überwachung, die die NSA irgendwie erlangen kann.
Maximal könnte, dass das maximale an Überwachung, was die NSA hinkriegen kann, ist deinen gesamten Internet-Traffic und alles, was du bei Google und Facebook hast, ja?
Google und Facebook haben aber im Prinzip schon so.
Neunzig, fünfundneunzig Prozent deines Internetverhaltens ohnehin, weil sie deine E-Mail äh lesen, die in der Regel,
Der normale äh Durchschnittsbürger hat ja dann auch nur so ein, zwei E-Mail Adressen, ja? Ähm.
Sie verfolgen dich auf jedem Schritt, wo du dich hin googelst und langklickst mit ihren äh Plus Plus One und Like Buttons, ja? Das heißt, die haben eine eine größere Kenntnis über die Nutzer als äh die als die NSA,
Und jetzt ist, glaube ich, zum ersten Mal der Punkt, dass,
Private Unternehmen, die primär wirtschaftliche Interessen verfolgen und diese Daten auch nur zu Wirtschaft in ihrem eigenen wirtschaftlichen Interesse nutzen,
Da letztendlich eine größere Macht haben als äh der Staat oder seine Geheimdienste.
Ja, dass also das finde ich, das muss man sich auch mal aus aus der Perspektive vor Augen führen, dass das heißt jetzt nicht, dass äh,
dass äh ich dafür plädiere, dass die Geheimdienste da jetzt auch dran dürfen, wenn es schon die äh wenn wenn es schon diese Unternehmen.
Ich finde, ich finde den Begriff äh macht an der Stelle insofern etwas äh deplatziert, weil.
Ich würde sagen, sie hätten die Möglichkeit. Ja, daraus äh äh daraus äh vielleicht auch Macht abzuleiten.
Noch nicht mal unterstellen, dass das wirklich ihr ihr Ziel ist. Das ist halt,
dieser diese duale Problematik dieser Daten, ne, um das zu tun, was sie eigentlich primär tun wollen, nämlich Geld verdienen, ja? Brauchen sie im Prinzip dieselben Daten, die ein Geheimdienst braucht, um,
seine äh,
Kontrolle über die Bevölkerung oder die Überwachung dieser Bevölkerung durch zu äh setzen. Das war ja früher nie so, also oder kaum so, dass irgendwie.
Primäres wirtschaftliches Interesse wirklich absolut Konkurrent ist mit einem Überwachungsinteresse durch einen Geheimdienst. Einfach eine neue Situation,
Ja, muss man sehen. Ich meine, was ich, was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass ja jetzt auch so ein das ist ja eigentlich auch relativ neu, ja, dass in der amerikanischen Öffentlichkeit jetzt überhaupt mal eine Debatte über Privatsphäre geführt wird.
Und du meinst äh äh die Dinge, die ich jetzt äh eigentlich absichtlich ausgeklammert hatte, dass äh Apple irgendwie ankündigt
die die Weißverschlüsselung sei jetzt äh
so das selbst sie nicht mehr darein backdown können und damit auch dem FBI nicht mehr helfen können. Du meinst, dass Eric äh Schmidt ähm ich glaube gestern dann öffentlich sagte, der sicherste Ort für deine Daten ist im Moment Google,
auf dieser Welt, ja. Äh wo wir da im Zweifelsfall recht hat. Es kommt halt drauf an, was du,
als drei dein Bedrohungsszenario siehst, so. Gelöscht werden die Daten da auf jeden Fall nicht mehr. So, also.
Ja, also, ja, oder, also ich wollte überhaupt nicht äh äh bewerten, ähm wie gut das ein oder andere Unternehmen,
Da er seinen eigenen Aussagen oder äh externen Anforderungen derzeit genügt, aber The Race ist on, also auf einmal ist ist das äh ein, ein, ein, äh, Aspekt. Es geht nicht nur um Funktionalität
Es geht nicht nur um irgendwie,
Maximal offen kommunizieren äh können, überhaupt maximal kommunizieren können. Äh es geht nicht mehr um sondern es geht auch dadrum.
Es geht darum, dass wir jetzt, glaube ich, ich weiß, ich bin da jetzt nicht so äh so Firmen und denkt da auch nicht so viel drüber nach, aber ich glaube, wir haben jetzt zum ersten Mal wirklich Konzerne.
Die größer sind und mächtiger als die Staaten.
Es gab immer irgendwie, ne, sehr, sehr entscheidende Lobbys und man konnte jetzt auch natürlich über die Banken sagen, sie sind mächtiger als die Staaten, weil im im allerschlimmsten Fall äh können sie die Staaten ganz einfach dazu bringen, ähm.
Quasi das Gesetz für sie außer Kraft zu setzen, mehr oder weniger und und ihren Schaden aufzufangen. Ähm aber so als als.
Als Entität, die unser Leben bestimmt. Ähm.
Ist Google halt wahrscheinlich äh und Facebook sind an der Grenze relevanter zu sein für das menschliche Miteinander, als es die äh.
Die staatlichen Mittel der Einflussnahme sind.
Ja denkbar. Immer gut, für das Miteinander fand ich den Staat jetzt noch nie so äh so richtig wichtig. Das war halt früher vielleicht eher eher der der Telefonbetreiber und das Postunternehmen, das irgendwie die Leute zusammengebracht hatten. Das ist halt.
Ja, aber die haben, die haben früher war's war Telekommunikationsdienstleistung, äh,
am Ende wirklich nur darauf beschränkt, diese Telekommunikation zu ermöglichen, ja? Ähm.
Und das ist ja, also das Themenfeld wird natürlich groß, deswegen fluchen ja jetzt auch diese ganzen Telekommunikationsanbieter und sind gegen Netzneutralität, weil sie irgendwie vermerken, dass sie da quasi äh,
Etwas Großartiges geschafft haben, mit dem sich Milliarden verdienen lassen, aber diese Milliarden nicht von ihnen verdichten werden.
Ja.
Ähm.
Na ja, die haben's ja nun gar nicht geschaffen.
Also ich muss es dann noch ich werde das mal noch mal irgendwie zu einem einem größeren konsistenteren Bild äh,
Zusammen formulieren, was ich vielleicht auch auch irgendwie klarer und flüssiger erklären kann. Aber dieser ähm dieser Aspekt, den finde ich schon sehr, sehr spannend, dass ähm.
Zwar da jetzt noch irgendwie so ein bisschen Klagerei los ist, ja und die irgendwie äh sich dagegen wehren, aber ähm.
Es scheint tatsächlich so zu sein, dass das diese Twitters und Googles.
Tatsächlich eventuell in die Situation kommen oder bald in der Situation sind, dass sie gegenüber einer Regierung und auch der US-Regierung nicht mehr äh bittstellend auftreten müssen.
Ja, das muss man mal sehen. Also bisher hatte ich so den Eindruck, ähm hat das noch nicht so gut äh verheilt, ne. Ich meine äh
Apple zum Beispiel ist ja da schon seit längerem sehr unzufrieden und hat von Anfang an drauf gedrängt. Das Interessante ist nur,
Apple hat genau keine keine Ausgaben für die klassische politische Bestechung in Form von Parteispenden.
Die machen einfach keine. Das kommt glaube ich.
Ist auch ein neues, auch fair.
Ja, ist auch fair, aber kommt irgendwie so beim Establishment halt irgendwie nicht so gut an. Habe ich so den Eindruck. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, irgendwie ist schon ist schon ist schon wirklich fies, ne? Ja.
Das nee, aber das wird das äh sehe ich als als äh Bestätigung meiner These. Die haben das nämlich nicht mehr notwendig. Die haben's nicht mehr nötig.
Bei Google ist es anders. Ja, also Google äh ist da äh nicht auf derselben Linie. Es ist aus ausschließlich äh Apple, die das so machen,
nebenbei halt derzeit Number one oder number two, Company of the World. So, je nachdem, wie man das so bewertet mit dieser ganzen Marktkapitalisierung, aber auf jeden Fall kein äh impotentes Unternehmen in der Hinsicht.
Na ja, ähm.
Wir spulen mal vor jetzt.
Genau, wir sind mal äh das Schönste, was dabei rauskommen kann bei diesen, bei dieser Klage von Twitter, könnte, wäre natürlich, dass diese ähm dass diese Gag, diese unsägliche äh National Security Letter Praxis irgendwann mal kippt.
Stark eingeschränkt wird.
Oder äh ja sinnvoll eingeschränkt wird. Insofern in den USA tut sich da auch was.
Und wir werden's natürlich wohlwollen verfolgen, wie Twitter da zum wiederholten Male äh sich hervortut als Speerspitze der Revolution.
So und äh unser beliebter neuer Veranstaltungsblog hat leider dieses Mal keine Einträge, von daher gibt's ihn nicht und wir äh müssen jetzt einfach mal direkt das Ende einleiten.
Wir haben im im Veranstaltungsblog einfach das letzte Mal schon unser Pulver verschossen.
Also neues Pulver bitte äh an uns, LMP Meterebene MI und ähm ja, kündigt uns äh ruhig mal an, was ihr an interessanten ähm,
Ideen so da ins Feld führt. Ist bei uns immer ganz gut aufgehoben.
Wollen wir hoffen, ja.
Genau. Und jetzt ist hier auch äh Schluss mit dem Geraune. Wir wünschen euch noch eine schöne Woche.
Genau und wir sind mal gespannt, wie die äh erscheinenden Frequenz in den nächsten vier Wochen wird dann halt wer weiß. Vielleicht steigt sie auch abrupt an.
Also geht schon mal alle in Deckung. Bis bald. Bis bald, ciao, ciao.
Bis bald, tschau, tschau.